did you know that Robert Downey Jr has
been trying to get Mel Gibson into the
Marvel Universe for years or that
Russell Crowe didn't want to play
Wolverine because he was afraid of being
Typecast as a lover of wolves we tend to
think of Marvel as being one of those
dream jobs for an actor but these are
the ones who decided to turn them down
there's a lot more to Jason Momoa than a
big brute he's played the character a
few times you might remember his stint
as Khal Drogo from Game of Thrones
this made Marvel think he'd be perfect
to play Drax on the Guardians of the
Galaxy but Jason found it to be a little
too similar to roles he'd played before
he compared it to the time he'd played
an alien on Stargate Atlantis who didn't
say much and grunted adding that he'd
been there and done that oh we fought
back the battle lasted days it seems it
just wasn't right for him which you have
to respect but even Jason would admit
that the part was perfectly cast and
that Dave Bautista was perfect and
speaking of perfect our next actress is
practically perfect in every way Emily
Blunt may not be meant for superhero
movies she wasn't just approached once
but twice by Marvel and turned them down
both times the first was when she was
asked to play Black Widow in Iron Man 2
but she stressed that she had to turn
them down because she was contractually
obligated to star in Gulliver's Travels
even though she'd say I didn't want to
do Gulliver's Travels I wanted to wait
with Robert Downey Jr would have been
amazing
ouch luckily Marvel gave Emily a second
chance a few years later when they
approached her to play Agent Carter but
again it didn't work out schedule wise
as it turns out Emily's not too upset
about it I don't know if superheroes are
for me and why is that it's been
exhausted at least that's a more normal
reason than our next one can you picture
Russell Crowe as Wolverine it's hard to
imagine anyone other than Hugh Jackman
but Russell is actually good friends
with Brian Singer who asked him to take
on the part first Russell however had
just finished filming Gladiator where
his character's companion was a wolf and
he didn't want to be seen as Wolfie like
Mr Wolf all of Russell's wolf related
scenes were cut from the final version
of gladiator anyway so he didn't need to
worry just like you don't have to worry
about clicking that subscribe button so
maybe take a minute to do that now still
apparently Russell got to see some
concept art of Wolverine they show me
art and stuff like that and it's like it
doesn't look like me and that gave
Russell an idea I'll tell you who it
looks like as it looks like you Jackman
sometimes recommendations go a long way
towards making Marvel history just not
so much in our next case now this one
would have been a controversial choice
for sure Mel Gibson was asked to play
Thor's dad a role that ultimately went
to the less polarizing Anthony Hopkins
Mel didn't really give a reason why he
turned it down simply saying that he
didn't do it but that isn't the last
run-in he would have with Marvel Mel is
friends with Robert Downey Jr he's even
responsible for helping Robert get
through a tough time if not for him who
knows we might have Tom Cruise as Iron
Man but more on that later for years
Roberts wanted to return the favor by
getting Mel involved in Marvel either on
screen like the time Robert championed
for Mel to join the Avengers in Infinity
war or end game that won't be pretty or
as a director like the time he argued
Mel should direct Iron Man 4. none of
which has happened for unknown reasons
what do you mean I haven't tried
everything what happened I tried how
cool would it have been to have Tom
Cruise as part of Marvel considering his
daring approach to stunts he would have
been right at home in a high action
superhero flick plus he played Maverick
in Top Gun which proves that he's down
for the aerial stuff this was probably
the sort of thinking that went into
Marvel offering him the role of Iron Man
back in the day but Tom says that as it
was lining up it just didn't feel to me
like it was gonna work he ultimately had
to turn it down but he has no regrets
even saying that he loves Robert Downey
Jr and that he can't imagine anyone else
in that role something that we might
have to agree with but in our next case
there may actually have been a bit of
hurt feelings involved Matthew
McConaughey took this one personally he
was asked to take on the role of ego in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. my name
is ego and I'm your dad bitter but what
Matthew saw was it's successful and now
we've got room to make a colorful part
for another big name actor he says that
he felt like an amendment around the
same time Matthew had also been offered
a role in The Dark Tower get ready tall
dark and handsome is about to crash the
party and he found this part to be much
more interesting phrasing the script and
the director so he decided to turn down
ego in favor of the Dark Tower
in the hell do you think you are but
everything seemed to work out with Kurt
Russell in the part sort of like Hal
Benedict Cumberbatch saved the day in
our next entry to view alternate Futures
it's important to Joaquin Phoenix that a
role be fulfilling if he were ever to
get involved with Marvel it would have
to be the right role and for a time we
thought that doctor strange could be
that part Joaquin had flirted with
several of those films having meetings
and getting close but nothing ever felt
right and so he decided to pass giving
Benedict Cumberbatch his chance to take
his spot I'm Dr Steven strange I need
you to come with me but you can't feel
too bad for Joaquin he said that
everybody was really happy with how
things turned out and would eventually
get his chance to play a comic book
character in The Joker how about another
joke Marie whether it was just too
similar to a previous role or the actor
didn't want to just feel like Second
Amendment there seems to be plenty of
reasons to turn down a roll with Marvel
so which one of these actors were you
most surprised to hear could have had a
part with the MCU make sure to let us
know in the comment section down below
foreign